[Musique]
il est 20 heures et les pompiers
viennent d'être averti qu un feu violent
s'est déclaré au nord ouest de paris a
bondi
un incendie d'une ampleur exceptionnelle
l'état major a fait partir une dizaine
de camions
las
[Musique]
c'est un garage qui a pris feu la
toiture s'est embrasée
ok approché du calaisis
à l'intérieur les flammes atteignent le
hall où sont exposés les voitures à
vendre
une affaire nous tourner
en plus de leur corps
est ce qu'ils vont attaquer le feu
s'équipe de leurs masques qui permet de
respirer malgré la fumée
leur objectif c'est de repousser les
flammes loin des voitures mais le
relance n'est pas opérationnel
immédiatement
[Musique]
à l'arrière du bâtiment il y à l'atelier
de réparation qui contient tellement de
produits et de matières inflammables que
l' incendie a pris en quelques minutes
une violence impressionnante
c'est ici que le feu a débuté il s'est
propagé à la toiture du bâtiment
les pompiers savent que le plus gros
danger est là dans ce toit traditionnel
maçonnerie et des socios seulement
l'acier
serons nous c'est la très mauvaise
stabilité d'acier au feu et donc son
effondrement
sous le toit et les plafonds qui brûlent
ceux qui sont à l'intérieur continuent
leur progression malgré les risques
d'effondrement malgré le plafond de plus
en plus inquiétant
les pompiers viennent d'apprendre que
des matières dangereuses de la peinture
de l'essence sont entreposés dans une
remise
juste à côté du garage les flammes ne
semble pas avoir atteint ce local pour
tenter d'éviter des explosions qui
rendrait la suite des événements plus
incontrôlable les pompiers décident d'y
pénétrer pour retirer tous ses produits
avant que le feu ne les atteignent
dans ce bidon 200 litres de liquide
inflammable
le feu est juste derrière cette porte en
bois
à l'extérieur les pompiers veulent
tenter de s'approcher plus du toit grâce
à la grande échelle
ce n'est que par là qu'ils auront une
chance de vaincre le feu s'ils ne
l'étaient n'y pas là ils ne pourront
plus rien faire reculer le danger
devient trop important de sous
vous avez tout là haut on ressort en ce
sens on va s'en aller
pourquoi pour sortir parce que plafond
est de construire et réparer donc toi et
en ressort nos photos nous ressort en
façade
la seule chose qu'ils peuvent faire
maintenant c'est empêcher l'incendié de
s'étendre aux bâtiments voisins
donc en cas de violence sur échelle pour
encore ici après empêcher la propagation
magasin de literie
[Musique]
face au risque est souvent comment
sauver ce qui est sauvable d'après le
propriétaire qui l'ont eu au téléphone
il n'y a personne à l'intérieur
les pompiers ne prendront plus le risque
d'entrer dans le bâtiment
il ne leur reste plus qu'à arroser de
loin et à attendre
les peu représentent que 6 à 7% nos
interventions lorsqu'on est présent
ce type d'intervention s'est toujours
fait toujours plaisir parce qu'un il ya
une concession tactique qui est
intéressante
et puis pour nous au point de vue
expériences et très très bien après une
heure de cet arrosage une équipe peut
pénétrer dans le garage pour éteindre
les derniers foyers dans l'atelier il y
avait 25 voiture qui attendait d'être
réparé et qui sont bonnes pour la casse
ils ont eu raison de ne pas prendre de
risques même si le plafond ne s'est pas
effondré les pompiers ont appris à ne
pas jouer au héros
surtout s'il n'y a pas de vie à sauver
intéressant
c'était un peu
la chance est sûre
sur nous on est là on à l'extérieur
ancrage bon bah c'est bien qu'on aime ça
c'est sûr que c'est dans un appartement
d'un immeuble sur 600 l'habitation n'a
peut-être une chance de faire un
sauvetage sauver une vie c'est le rêve
de tous les sapeurs pompiers sauver une
vie sa part de vie qui fait ça dans sa
carrière c'est bon il est heureux il
seule fois ça suffit d'en faire 36 saut
vers une vie tous les pompiers de france
le dit c'est pour cela qu'ils sont
devenus pompiers tous ont rêvé un jour
d'intégrer la brigade la brigade
c'est comme cela que l'on appelle les
pompiers de paris ils sont à part ce
sont des militaires ils ont la renommée
et le prestige de soldats d'élite
le véhicule de premiers secours vient de
décaler de la caserne d'aubervilliers
est calée dans le jargon ça veut dire
tout simplement partir à la suite d'un
appel
cette fois il décale pour une personne
malade une intervention a priori banale
mais lorsqu'ils partent pour porter
secours à une victime
ils ne savent jamais trop ce qui les
attend
non les chiens vous risquez rien croit
que la jeune femme est la voisine c'est
elle qui a appelé le 18
l'homme qui paraît muet semble ne pas
vouloir des secours
il vit avec sa mère et la voisine
explique que c'est pour protéger la
vieille dame qu'elle a appelé les
pompiers
partez l'homme est en état d'ébriété la
venue des pompiers ne le calme pas dans
un premier temps il les bouscule fuit il
va carrément chercher à leur donner des
coups et par magie il retrouve la parole
ouais allez on se calme un été calme et
là n'est pas là pour prendre des coups
donc il est hors de question qu'on en
prenne en rien donner du tout tu vas
finir chez les ch maîtrise qui s'est
passé tu essayais nous frapper on n'est
pas morts on n'est pas là pour prendre
des coups donc là pour télé tu nous
envoie chier on vient pour moi le bilan
des opérations les schmitz et la police
vous essayez nous a collé une droite
vous rigolez pas un peu n'aurait même
pas discuter toute façon indiscutable
monsieur c
alors ça va venir au commissariat en
garde à vue et comme tout le temps de
faire confiance vous lâchera pas
d'accord le chef de l'équipe décide de
demander l'assistance de la police
tu peux me faire la police pour assurer
agressif envers les secours c'est un peu
long
l'angola qui parle c'est moi l'abruti a
déjà c'est pas un abruti déjà c'est
monsieur ces banques arrivé très tôt mme
ashton
bois et matin à moi j'évolue déroulait
la gay bénin d'une pièce d'identité
sa date de naissance
c'était quoi le monde me dit ça monsieur
conrad et là nous sommes en rose bonbon
lui sait trop quel contraste rockhal
reste qu'elle s'aggrave
on arrête les bêtises quel âge qui nous
avait je pense que c'était le moment de
faire des bêtises comme ça en toute
amitié joue il dit un quart d'heure plus
tard la police arrive
monsieur c'est la police là on peut
parler bien sûr
alors qu'est-ce qui se passe écoutez
vous êtes déjà assise assez violent a
donc un cola ils vont pas prendre le
reste on put bureau va écouter confiance
ou pas parce que sinon ça va se passer
très vite ses droits des menaces
monsieur mambé n'est pas d'hier il a
cédé commencer un conseil attend à
savoir ce qui se passe alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé là bas monsieur c'est
oublierez sa sauce et palau
les policiers décident d'emmener l'homme
au commissariat pour le placer en
cellule de dégrisement lörrach au
commissariat les pompiers n'aime pas ce
genre de situation mais leurs consignes
sont claires ils ne doivent jamais
prendre le risque de recevoir des coups
là si on ne faisait pas moi chez kelme
arrivée dans la tête
le point elle était direct dedans vit
avec sa mère la grande piste
ils squattent seront tous les soirs
rarement au coeur de l'asie
puis temps en temps ça peut me faire
plaisir y met des coups à sa mère aussi
donc c'est vraiment légèrement désolant
c'est la vie après fait ainsi
faire partie de l'équipe du premier
secours c'est effectivement chaque fois
découvrir de nouveaux aspects de la vie
pas toujours les meilleurs le sapeur
cédric boully à 22 ans sûrement pas la
caserne sera bien le filet par cédric
est un jeune sapeur pompier il vient
d'arriver à la caserne d'aubervilliers
après ces quatre mois de formation au
centre d'instruction de la brigade
il s'est engagé pour cinq ans il savait
ce qui l'attendait son père et pompiers
de paris depuis 35 ans je suis un fils
de pompier d'un adjudant chef qu'à
bientôt est à la retraite ou 35 ans de
service je suis né à la brigade je suis
né dedans donc j'ai toujours vécu en
caserne jeu toujours a été au contact
des pompiers du métier
à chaque fois que je pouvais aller jouer
c'était dans la cour de la caserne
c'était peut-être même à est monté dans
les engins et puis faire semblant de
décaler regard des engins partir c'est
sûr que ça crée des vocations
la réalité n'est peut-être pas tout à
fait au niveau des rêves de gamins qui
jouaient aux héros dans la cour de la
caserne
[Applaudissements]
ce n'est pas une voiture qui vous a
touché que ce qui s'est passé
vous marchez sur le trottoir je vais
tomber
pour moi le métier de pompier ça
commence d'abord par le feu ce que je
veux faire en premier malheureusement je
n'ai pas fait de feu d'habitation encore
ou sinon si j'en ai fait c'était pas les
victimes s'étaient pas des grands ou en
feu où il ya des flammes qui sortent des
fenêtres mais c'est ce que c'est dans en
fait on attend presque le malheur des
gens que c'est ce qu'on sait c'est
malheureux à dire mais quand on fait un
peu on est content quoi
[Musique]
on paraît plus utile quand on va aller
chercher quelqu'un avec l'échelle plutôt
que quand on va ramasser quelqu'un qu'on
état d'ébriété ça c'est sûr
l'ébriété comme ça c'est le quotidien de
la nuit la sté beaujolais hier l'équipe
de garde vient d'être appelé parce
qu'une personne âgée ne répond pas aux
appels
ce genre d'intervention ils en font 8500
parents un malaise une absence ou pire
un décès les pompiers ne savent jamais
ce qu'ils vont trouver derrière la porte
je suis descendu parce que je sais les
voisins et sont inquiétés non mais
malgré moi on va vous aider à retourner
vers votre fauteuil
il a l'air
[Musique]
les uns parlent tout le temps comme ça
vous allez bien le métier pompiers c'est
vraiment se projeter dans l'avenir que
c'est se dire qu'est ce que j'ai fait ma
vie j'ai fait quelque chose de concret
d' intéressant et j'ai apporté quelque
chose aux autres
ensuite c'est être confronté à la misère
voir des personnes âgées qui sont
totalement seuls chez eux qu'ils
convoquent une aide quoi qui seront
jamais visité des gens qui vivent dans
des dents de la saleté qui nettoie
jamais chez eux ça c'est ce froid que
c'est le plus immonde quoi presque des
bêtes là dedans dans l'eure dans leur
appart
ça au moins on me la raconter d'accord
je le savais mais tant qu'on l'a pas vu
je crois qu'on s'imagine pas voilà allez
au revoir
ça fait peu de temps que tu es chez les
pompiers ce que tu es déjà blindé moi je
suis je pas insensible à la détresse des
gens quoi que ce soit que j'espère que
les options plus on donne de la voix ce
malheur c'est mal en question ont soit
39 plus trop sur soi parce qu'après
c'est à chaque intervention on commence
à prendre sur soi bon voilà quoi
c'est triste mais bon c'est comme ça on
va pouvoir y faire on peut rien faire de
plus malheureusement
pensant recommande morgan l'accasion
d'aubervilliers à l'appel sapeurs
bourgeois sapeurs charpentier feu
comme tous les lundis c'est un rituel
les hommes de la brigade rendent hommage
à leurs morts
il n'oublie pas les noms des 26 pompiers
de paris tu es en cours d'intervention
depuis la deuxième guerre mondiale repos
tapis rouge pour la planche l'exercice
de la planche c'est chaque matin chaque
pompier de paris doit montrer qu'il est
capable de se hisser à la force des bras
sur une planche situe à 2 m 20 du sol
c'est un petit test de forme
tous les jours on apprend que vous avez
une partie forces tirent une traction
s'établir sur la planche pas évident la
tenue de feu est lourde et rend les
gestes maladroits qui échoue n'aura pas
le droit de décaler le secteur de la
caserne d'aubervilliers aux portes nord
de la capitale est un point sensible il
est couvert d'entrepôt c'est l'endroit
où il y a le plus d'un cent dix chez les
pompiers être passé par aubervilliers
c'est la référence l'adjudant ligier le
chef du centre d'aubervilliers
on arrive dans la zone d'activités de la
porte d'aubervilliers on voit des
magasins tous les côtés problème c'est
que c'est une activité aussi qu' à
risque puisqu'ils ont ils entreposent
des matériaux très très combustible du
tissu des bibelots et puis les entrepôts
ont pas été mis aux normes
c'est encore du vieux entrepôts alors là
vous avez une camionnette à ça ça fait
partie aussi des nombreux feux ont fait
un regard des et quand elle est trop
près de notre propre foule fait
l'entrepôt voilà une maroquinerie nos
qui a complètement brûlé qui
s'effondraient les feux d'aubervilliers
son célèbre le 1er décembre 1995
un incendie a ravagé un entrepôt des
magasins généraux les pompiers mettront
plusieurs heures pour en venir à bout
les quatre étages du bâtiment vont
s'effondrer il ne restera plus que la
façade en juin 1999 un autre entrepôt
des jouets des parfums de la lingerie et
des briquets tout brûle des incendies
spectaculaires qui entretiennent la
réputation de la caserne d'aubervilliers
d'autant qu'il existe des points plus
dangereux que les entrepôts les docks
d'alcool la réserve d'alcool de tout
paris pour moi c'est le plus sensible de
mon secteur
c'est ça prend un peu moins les risques
d'explosion et puis ce sont des feux
très difficile à atteindre
feu feu d'alcool fait solvants polaire
très très difficile a été derrière on a
un atelier de conditionnement des white
spirit de l'alcool à brûler l'essence de
térébenthine que des matières très
inflammables
et bien c'est parti à partir du moment
où il ya l'ordre n'officie à toi pour
sauvetage d'une victime au quatrième
étage on est allés chez à l'accrocher
dressé l'échelle leur réputation les
hommes d'aubervilliers y tiennent ici on
prend l'entraînement très au sérieux
messieurs si vous voulez dans les temps
il faut savoir tu pour chaque étage vous
devez les avoir monté en une minute
gérard manset dure toujours
l'appréhension samad atypique on voit si
si on est bien en condition physique et
si on connaît bien la manoeuvre oublie
pas le pousser un petit pécule
messieurs vous êtes monté en 41 dépêchez
vous
ultima consciente en fait laisse
automatiquement tu te blesses icitap la
faune jus mais tu t'énerves traces sur
son matos là tu reste lucide calmer
l'une étant donné qu'on a pas le feu et
la fumée
on l'aimait vraiment la situation nous
on est là pour les pousser provoqué ce
type de stress de façon à accélérer la
manoeuvre
[Musique]
je suis vous êtes entendre vous
essouffler en plus vous avez la fumée
autant vous dire vous êtes en train de
vous fixiez vous êtes à 6 minutes et
vous
[Musique]
de se voir l'essor écart-là du mur êtes
vous fait une descente ou c'est une
promenade dégâts dire pauvre petite
chose à aujourd'hui on a un caporal-chef
qui n'égale pas et sur ses manoeuvres à
et pousse pour mieux avoir un
instructeur dynamique qu'à la pêche
comme instructeur qui a tendance à
s'endormir
oui il a bien le profil de l'instructeur
dynamique un type à la rambo qui pousse
ses gains et dont certains commencent à
essayer de s'identifier à lui le
prennent en exemple à troyes 1 2 3 ok
une fois je lé là après je viens
chercher l'actus des pôles
je suis chaque côté j'ai plus qu'à
engager t'emmerde pas avec ses sangles
match palais semble 6,6 à la une jupe un
toit c'est mona sahlin je continue à
chercher ensemble
il est là pour talons ici c'est
nettement mieux d'avoir un bout de
pantalons d'avoir une sangle qui va te
laisser sept jours il est 15 heures et
nous sommes là lorsqu'un message tombe
sur le télex feu aux docks d'alcool 150
pompiers 25 camions sont envoyés sur
place
[Musique]
dans la vingtaine de cuves 6500 mètres
cubes d'alcool 6 millions et demi de
litres
le feu n'a pas pris dans ses cuves mais
à moins de 50 mètres de l'autre côté de
ce bâtiment l'atelier de conditionnement
où est stocké du white spirit
si l'atelier prend feu tous sont sur
place les pompiers découvrent que c'est
une conduite de gaz qui s'est enflammée
c'est le gaz qui fuient que l'on voit
brûler
seul ce mur sépare les flammes des
stocks de white spirit
nadal pour la chaufferie donc
celle là où trop ce qu'on dit ça de la
haute pression cela veut dire que le
tuyau qui fuit dépend du réseau
d'alimentation du quartier seuls des
employés de gaz de france pourront
trouver les vannes pour arrêter la fuite
et tant que le gaz fuit il faut surtout
le laisser brûler fuite de gaz enflammée
au risque de voir le gars se répandre un
peu partout sans maîtriser toki faut
barrer et ensuite progressivement en
force d'alico
le souci c'est qu'on a le top des
alcools c'est juste derrière avec des
gros stockage de produits fiscalement
inflammables explosifs
effectivement si le gaz se répandait les
risques d'explosion serait plus grand
encore
pendant que les employés du gaz de
france cherche à barrer c'est-à-dire à
fermer les vannes qui arrêteront la
fuite
les pompiers veulent tenter de protéger
les stocks de white spirit
leur idée c'est de placer une équipe de
l'autre côté du mur pour empêcher le feu
de pénétrer dans le bâtiment
la fuite est situé derrière un petit
atelier dont la porte est fermée à clé
les pompiers ne savent pas ce qu'il ya à
l'intérieur des coups de masse pour
défoncer la porte
le feu est déjà là
[Musique]
les pompiers veulent placer une lance
la flamme bleue c'est du gaz qui brûle
il ne faut pas l'éteindre
ils aperçoivent surtout au milieu des
flammes deux bonbonnes métalliques
dans des politiques nous avons découvert
deux bouteilles d'acétylène c'est qui
nous impose d'avoir pu lire dans notre
vie
pourtant on a protégé mon portelance
dans le cas d'un risque d'explosion
le risque est devenu considérable
pourtant au départ ce n'était pas grand
chose une voiture en flammes et un
témoin qui ne parvient pas à l'éteindre
moi j'ai vu brûler la voiture je suis
approché j'ai percuté deux si c'est une
conséquence on suit à la lettre g est
aussi celle
quand j'ai attaqué le feu j'ai percuté
mais deux extincteurs si ç'avait été que
la voiture je les aurais pas la faute
sur j arrivais pas y avait une
réalimentation derrière permanence la
suite de gasques variante sales gosses
qui aboient je vais vous demander de
rester dans la partie
les bouteilles d'acétylène et puis tous
ces bidons sur les palettes ils sont
remplis d'alcool à brûler de white
spirit
au bout de trois quarts d'heure les
employés du gaz ont fini par trouver les
vannes les flammes s'éteignent les
pompiers continuent d'arroser pour
refroidir
il s'approche avec prudence le risque
d'explosion n'est pas écartée dans
l'atelier les bouteilles d'acétylène ont
tenu mais les pompiers savent que l'on a
frôlé la catastrophe
l'adjudant ligier n'est pas en tenue de
feu ils étaient de repos mais dès qu'il
a su le patron de la caserne est
accourue cette poudrière au milieu de
son territoire ne le laisse pas
tranquille
la voiture qui a pris feu ce soir un
acte de malveillance soirée problèmes
technologiques qui va propager à feu un
établissement vétuste à une conduite de
gaz et ça c'est arrivé dans le quartier
plusieurs fois ces temps ci une heure
plus tard le feu est entièrement éteints
la police scientifique va devoir établir
l'origine de l'incendié les pompiers ont
fait leur travail
le capitaine nadal peut retourner dans
sa caserne il vient d'aulnay sous bois
une quinzaine de kilomètres au nord
d'aubervilliers
l'état major avait fait venir des engins
de tout le département
le capitaine nadal à 39 ans il est entré
à la brigade comme simple sapeur
heureusement on peut arriver vite après
17 années de service incendie le
capitaine est toujours impressionné par
les interventions d'aubervilliers cadeau
pour la réputation d'être des guerriers
du feu et des gens qui sont habitués à
faire pas mal de feu et de ceux qui sont
qualifiés atypique qui sont un petit peu
de l'ordinaire dans son secteur à aulnay
sous bois
c'est tout autre chose
la particularité des pompiers donner
c'est de faire beaucoup de ceux de local
à vide-ordures de feu de véhicule de
tourisme qui sont des feux d'origine il
faut bien le dire
d'origine malveillante pour la plupart
pas essentiellement mais pour la paix
pas donc on peut dire que nous sommes
sont terriblement entraîner
les soumis à rude épreuve en ce qui
concerne donc les feux de véhicules de
tourisme
les soldes d'hiver mais sur voie
publique la caserne d'aulnay sous bois
neuf heures du soir leur routine
on vient de leur annoncer un feu de
poubelle dans une des cités non loin de
la caserne
le secteur de la compagnie d'aulnay sous
bois ce sont 114 sites et dont 4 ou 5
des plus chaudes de la banlieue nord en
juin dernier des troubles avaient éclaté
entre des bandes de jeunes et les
policiers des pompiers avaient été
agressés depuis il se méfie
[Musique]
segal si tu vois que c'est louche
tu te dira aussi si jamais tu veux
descendre tu t'habilles
donnez des habitants explique qu'ils
sont vu des jeunes mettre le feu aux
poubelles
d'accord nous attendait là dans cette
cité les poubelles sont toujours à
l'extérieur des immeubles pour éviter
que les feux ne se transmette aux
appartements
sur les huit communes du secteur les
pompiers ont éteint 650 feu de poubelle
l'année dernière quand on vient ici en
général on assez prudents parce qu'on a
été agressé dans le passé et c'était à
chaque fois dans cette année ou dans la
très proches dans les rues très proche
c'est ce qu'on appelle sevran beaudottes
la cité des beaudottes ils s'y sont fait
agresser 16 fois l'an dernier on reste
sur nos gardes quoi disons qu'avec
l'expérience on prend des précautions
ça change en rien notre façon
d'intervenir on prend juste un petit peu
plus de recul
il s'est vite aussi d'effacer les traces
des incendies des glaces mais des fois
je sensibilise un petit peu les gens
aussi de par rapport à ce qui se passe
mais de toute façon on va pas tourner
dans la poubelle c'est sûr parce que
sinon ils vont mettre le sera
les agressions que les pompiers
redoutent ce sont des jets de pierre sur
leur camion
les fameux caillassage
tu as fait si dans les portes claquent
bien
j'ai pas lui qui a jeté la pierre on a
juste vu des gens qui étaient à trouver
des jeunes qui est bien entendu de
de boom donc mon avis de les jeunes ils
ont ils ont balancé des cailloux quoi
comme à l'habitude c'est des bandes de
jeunes qui traînent le soir ce n'est
qu'à leur retour à la caserne
ils prennent le temps de constater les
dégâts
il y en a qui toute la nuit il décale
pour des gens qui ont trop vu ben nous
on décale pour des choses comme ça donc
là le pire c'est là-haut ou la vache oui
ouais et puis ici par non non
oh
cent ans jour
[Musique]
on va aller porter plainte
au commissariat de sevran l'an dernier
ils ont déposé 39 plainte pour ces
caillassages
je dirais qu'il ya vraiment une petite
minorité qui c'est la pagaille et puis
le reste qui prend pour eux sur 99% des
interventions qu'on fait les gens sont
très amicaux
les pompiers ne comprennent pas cette
agressivité pas plu à paris que dans les
autres villes de france où des camions
rouges deviennent la cible des cailloux
dans les cités à aulnay sous bois
il arrive que les pompiers soient
appelés pour d'autres raisons que pour
des feux de poubelles ou des incendies
de voitures
une fuite de gaz
mais la cité
derrière la caserne a cité rougemont
ça peut être dangereux dans le cas ou si
c'est une grosse fuite et l époque de
gad
en milieu exposés
donc dès l'entrée on va sentir si ça
sent vraiment beaucoup viennent
d'ailleurs a sûrement danger en fait
deux milieu explosif
le danger pourrait bien venir d'autre
chose que du gaz et les pompiers sentent
tout de suite une hostilité
ok ça marche
[Musique]
l'appel venait du 4e étage de cet
immeuble le propriétaire a senti une
odeur de gaz chez lui dans le doute les
pompiers n'allume pas la lumière
les voix en dessous la circulent des
soirs où on est effectivement que c'est
sans quoi un sens ça sera la colme là
ici là attendre là on sent bien là les
choses
l'odeur en question ce n'est pas du gaz
les pompiers croient comprendre de quoi
il s'agit ils descendent au
rez-de-chaussée de l'immeuble bobinette
qu'ils perdent les sens voilà le
problème c'est l'odeur de l'essence de
cette moto qui est remonté par les
conduits d'aération
mais les pompiers vont vite comprendre
qu'ils n'en ont pas fini avec cette cité
ah bah oui à l'extérieur d'une poubelle
est en train de brûler une provocation
on compterait pas trop rester sourd on
va s'écarter des murs
et soit on soumet dessous on s'écarte
des murs parce que les objets volants
non identifiés arrive souvent sur notre
tête comme ça donc pourquoi ils ont
allumé ce prix là je sais pas du tout
franchement qu'est ce qui leur passe
dans la tête des forts
sans capote baissée ça va c'est quand il
y en a vingt nous met la rage mais c'est
pas ça qui nous empêche de parvenir au
même endroit et les continuer à aider
les gens
on sera prêt en à partie par une bande
on verra bien donner envie de vous
défendre vous êtes tous costaud j'ai
compris on va dire que la violence
entraîne la violence et que
si jamais on se défend il faudra
toujours se dire qu'ils sont toujours
plus et que nous on sera toujours là si
nous appelle on viendra toujours
donc ça sera trop facile pour eux nous
avoir donc on cherche même pas c'est pas
notre travail ça fera que la police est
là pardon
[Musique]
dans l'angle haoussa juste à côté la ta
rennes 1 qui vient avec moi
je vais pas y aller tout ça non plus
dans le local à poubelles d'une autre
entrée un autre feu
[Musique]
tant qu'on va rester là mon avis comment
faire
toujours une force brute et où leur tête
leur famille peut être y réfléchir
pour un stand
lorsqu'ils reviennent à la caserne un
autre véhicule rentre également d'un feu
de poubelle dans une autre cité c'est le
camion des premiers secours qui avait
essuyé quelques jets de pierres deux
jours plus tôt cette fois un caillou n'a
pas raté la vitre
plus étonnant en roulant il savait
entendu des pas sur le toit
il ya des traces de pas sur le toit
quelqu'un est monté sur le camion alors
qu'il roulait et est allé casser le
gyrophare de d'ordures il ya un arbre
juste à côté je pense que c'était dans
l'arbre on entendu le gyrophare explosé
on est descendu le ramasser puis là il a
répété la vie les vitres ont été traités
ils ont mis un film de manière à ce que
les bouts de verre ne se répande pas
suaire nouveau stade
désespérante peut-être la chance qu'on
est des films plastiques huîtres parce
qu'autrement est dangereux lancé ça le
pire
suivront si effectivement les gens
stationnent sur le toit et que pris de
panique le conducteur redémarre que le
jeune homme tombe de la hauteur du quai
bien et sur la chaussée ridicule qui
suivent derrière ça peut effectivement
être un jeu plus que dangereux donc la
vitre est complètement brisée mais elle
est tenue par le film plastique
donc je suis pas à l'abri qu'un deuxième
aime pas que suite à ce soir si ça
chauffe un peu parce qu'il fait bon et
puis il faut se trouvait dehors
donc est ce qu'il ya un enjeu
indisponibles merci donc humain
disponible vous profiterez pour changer
le un gyrophare détruit une vitre cassée
un camion envoyé en réparation et cela
fait un véhicule de secours en moins sur
le secteur d'aulnay sous bois
un peu plus tard cette nuit là ils sont
appelés pour un feu de voiture
[Musique]
ils savent ce qui les attend ils savent
que quelques jeunes désoeuvrés ont
décidé de jouer avec eux
sur nes présent
l'an dernier huit cent trente voitures
ont été brûlées ainsi sur les huit
communes du secteur
ces incendies sont tous criminels mais
la police n'a pas toujours les moyens de
venir sur place
nous sommes à quelques jours du 31
décembre les pompiers redoutent cette
fin d'année l'an dernier quelques bandes
des cités alentours se sont amusés à
déclencher des incendies partout dix
sept voitures ont brûlé
heureusement l'an dernier il n'y a pas
eu de catastrophe mais ils craignent
qu'un jour cela se finisse mal
[Musique]
les pompiers de paris sont appelés par
la police du côté d'aubervilliers
une femme fait une crise de nerfs sur la
voie publique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette femme est ivre elle hurle parce
que sa soeur qui est enceinte de trois
mois aurait été blessé cet épicier
voulait fermer son magasin il aurait
poussé la soeur enceinte dehors elles
auraient raté la marche et serait tombé
par terre
[Musique]
alors est ce que vous en faites moselle
de secours
oui
elle a rien du tout elle a juste vous
plaît non la police n'a pas l'air très
motivé pour emmener la jeune femme au
commissariat d'autant qu'il n'y a pas
vraiment de raison sa soeur n'a rien de
grave
votre soeur elle va bien elle avait mal
au ventre
c'est elle qui me l'a dit elle a juste 2
qui plaît alors on a prié pansement mais
là ça va
[Musique]
à l'évidence les policiers ne veulent
pas s'embarrasser d'une ivrogne
hystérique
ils ont précisé à la soeur qu'elle devra
se présenter au commissariat si elle
veut porter plainte
[Musique]
pour éviter que cela se termine par un
accident les pompiers décident d'emmener
la soeur enceinte à l'hôpital mais
livrent à une nappe eu l'air d'accord
elle veut maintenant amener sa soeur
chez elle d'accord on vous laisse là
mais moi je reviens pas dans cinq
minutes parce que vous êtes rouler par
terre à jean vient pendant cinq minutes
on est quand même pompier en un service
d'urgence on n'est pas là ce soir les
musées le décor dès demain vous faites
ce coup
la blessure
oui
le bilan de la faire on a rien à faire
mais si jamais il y en a un qui se fait
shooter on est responsable les superbes
l'intervention des pompiers de paris qui
a su en bio garnier disponibles la
caserne de ménilmontant il est deux
heures du matin
l'ambulance de réanimation est appelée
en renfort pour un feu qui s'est déclaré
dans un hôtel du centre de paris
plusieurs casernes envoie des secours il
y aurait des victimes dans un état très
grave
[Musique]
le pompier qui courent devant nous et
médecins c'est le dsm le directeur des
secours médicaux en cas de catastrophe
avec beaucoup de victimes son rôle est
de coordonner l'ensemble des secours
à son arrivée les pompiers ont déjà
sorti les victimes de l'hôtel elles ont
été prises en charge par d'autres
médecins pompiers par des équipes du
samu
trois clients ont été retrouvés inanimés
dans un couloir dans la panique il avait
fait ce qu'il ne faut pas faire ils
avaient quitté leur chambre
deux adultes sont dans le coma la
troisième victime est un petit garçon de
10 ans son coeur avait cessé de battre
lorsque les pompiers l'ont trouvé ils
ont réussi à faire repartir ce coeur
mais l'enfant est dans un coma profond
incendie pourtant n'a pas été très
violent mais les fumées sont dangereuses
elles se sont propagées par la cage
d'escalier
l'hôtel est plutôt luxueux mais
l'installation électrique était ancienne
c'est un court circuit qui a déclenché
les flammes
c'est à cet étage à proximité du feu que
l'on a retrouvé les trois victimes
encore pour l'instant d'éclaircir
les pompiers ne savent pas si le petit
garçon était avec les deux adultes
rien ne permet de les identifier
on fait à
le directeur des secours c'est le
docteur giocanti qui assurait la
permanence à la caserne de ménilmontant
pour tout paris cette nuit là il doit
donc coordonner le travail des
différents médecins urgentistes et
s'occuper de toutes les victimes
même celles qui semblent ne pas avoir
grand chose
les occupants des autres chambres de
l'hôtel ont pu sortir par les fenêtres
si certains ont respiré un peu de fumée
aucun n'est dans un état grave
c'est tous les gens qui sont plus que
c'est tous deux légers 1 par mois
on essaye de faire un petit riz amer
ceux qui ont un peu une année les autres
qui n'ont vraiment rien se mettront au
fond le gros problème c'est le gamin
voudrait voir son identité savoir où
sont ses parents tous ses parents c'est
le samu qui dès le début a pris en
charge le petit garçon
le gamin là ses parents où sont passés
les 2
normal deux adultes au mal d'accord donc
on sait pas où sont les parents qui
gamin la plupart des occupants de
l'hôtel sont des touristes américains ce
qui ne simplifie pas les recherches
ok vous retournez dans le
dans le poste de
d'accord
d'abord les identités on
laisser comme ça dans un état grave va
bien sûr méchant avec une catastrophe
la chambre doit être carbonisés on n'a
aucune identité pour les trois blessés
graves s'est pas qui c'est pour la il ya
moins une bonne chose c'est que le coeur
du petit garçon est reparti donc
maintenant c'est pas dans quel état ils
et neurologiquement ça va être
l'hôpital qui veulent déterminer dans
quelques jours l'enfance quand même état
alors là c'est impossible de faire le
moindre pronostic castillo absolument
empocher les trois victimes sont emmenés
vers l'hôpital vers un service de
réanimation
personne ne sait qui sont ces gens là
personne s'apparente donc on est allé
faire des reconnaissances en a demandé à
tout le monde on a recueilli les maximum
de renseignements en même temps fallait
porter secours il fallait organiser
l'évacuation de leur deuxième
recensement
donc là tout est tranquille tout al'air
terminé on espère que c'est terminé qui
a pas les parents qui attendent des
nouvelles têtes avant quelques parme a
priori non je pense qu'il était avec les
deux adultes
en fait les deux adultes était un homme
et une femme c'était les parents du
petit garçon tous deux s'en sont sortis
leur fils est mort à l'hôpital trois
jours plus tard
[Applaudissements]
la caserne de ménilmontant dans le 20e
arrondissement ces lacs est installé le
docteur giocanti les médecins militaires
et pompiers de paris depuis huit ans
jours lorsqu'il n'est pas en
intervention il s'occupe de la santé des
pompiers
bonjour ça va
le caporal-chef bd lem a été gravement
brûlée lors d'une intervention à ce que
vous vous rapprochez vous bon en fait un
petit peu le point là de ses brûlures 1
pour les circonstances et l attaque de
ses biens sentis d'appartement c'est à
dire par rayonnement ça va être à
travers la travers avec la conduction
quoi rire le cuir vous l'avez senti tout
de suite ou pas ça chauffe et ça
chauffait dur et quand ça s'enflamme et
le mal était fait et a privé le torse nu
de gaza le pompier qui vient chez nous
n'est pas tranquille
il tient beaucoup à son aptitude au
service incendie il tient beaucoup à
faire son métier et sait qu'on a le
pouvoir de supprimer temporairement voir
définitivement cette aptitude au service
incendie
donc parfois il a tendance un petit peu
nous dissimuler des choses et pas de
douleur dans les différents mouvements
flexion extension ya pas de douleur ça
tire un peu et au toucher au moins ça
fait un peu mal quoi c'est sensible où l
on sait sensible
ouais d'accord dans l'autre côté vous
avez entamé votre capital peau on hésite
à vous renvoyer un service incendie n'a
pas du tout envie que vous soyez victime
d'une deuxième brûlures ça m'étonnerait
qu'on vous fasse prendre le service à
100 d'accord
mais votre carrière au revoir sa
quelconque problème n'hésitez pas à me
contacter l'an dernier 2 169 pompiers de
paris ont été blessés en intervention et
55 d'entre eux ont été victimes de
brûlures
pourtant le métier de pompier n'est pas
considéré comme une profession à risque
le docteur giocanti vient d'être appelé
en renfort par des pompiers qui se
trouve du côté de la bastille
[Musique]
mon cher
je
parmi nos moniteurs vous êtes appelés
sur quoi
une fusillade
on a fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
combien
chacun
un quart d'heure plus tôt une moto est
venu à la hauteur de cette voiture
bloqué dans un embouteillage
un passager à l'arrière de la moto a
mitraillé à bout portant le conducteur
15 balles ont été tirées
onze ont atteint leur cible trois balles
dans le thorax et dans l'abdomen une
balle dans le bras
5e impact en plein emploi en face du
coeur
je pense que malheureusement un mal se
terminer
on masse quand même la règle veut
combats seront trentaine de minutes
un règlement de comptes
l'homme était un repris de justice
l'ambulance de l'animation elle est
capable de faire face à tout type de
détresse vraiment tous types de détresse
on touche à tous les domaines à la
médecine d'urgence à la médecine de
prévention à la médecine d'enseignement
c'est vraiment une affectation une
affectation exceptionnel pour des
situations parfois exceptionnelles nous
sommes à montreuil dans l'appartement
d'un couple de personnes âgées
cet homme de 99 ans a voulu se suicider
mais les pompiers ne parviennent pas à
savoir ce qu'il a fait le vieux monsieur
est conscient mais il ne répond pas aux
questions du docteur giocanti monsieur
ouvrez les yeux
c'est les pompiers la couvrait les yeux
les yeux monsieur va chez patou ci s'est
passé comment vous l'avez trouvé les
cris les choses qu'est ce qu'il a écrit
je veux mourir je me coupais une
nouvelle
il avait l'intention d'être un séjour
c'est toi qui l'a écrit mais là rien non
il avoue s'agir la tap et puis avait mis
grand couteau a compté il parlait de se
couper les veines ma part moi n'en a
rien fait il a menacé de faire quelque
chose c'est parce qu'il a fait qu'est-ce
qu'il avait votre mari là il n'avait pas
le moral ces derniers temps non létales
voulait mourir
ouais d'accord qu'est ce qu'il a fait à
votre avis la vallée des médicaments non
non d'accord d'accord ça veut dire que
je suis chez les pompiers bon voilà on
va l'amener à saint-antoine a priori
pourquoi mais non madame
mais non mais non je vous en donne ma
parole on va s'en occuper
d'accord je les connais à saint-antoine
je vais leur en parler vont bien s'en
occuper de votre main mais non madame c
ya combien de temps mais non c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai nom à saint-antoine
san hôpital moderne on soigne très bien
les gens vous inquiétez pas
je pense que ça fait quarante ou
cinquante ans qui ensemble
la pauvre petite dame retrouve son mari
qui dit qu'il va se suicider tout
susciter à 99 ans ce à quoi lui donner
un petit coup au moral
la pauvre dame voilà rassurés même si
tout n'est pas rassurée à cette triste
vouloir mettre fin à ses jours à 99 ans
ou tout du moins d'être désespérée
[Musique]
crépuscule de sa vie
bon bah merci avance attends-toi de rock
est en fait le vieux monsieur n'avait
rien absorber
la caserne d'aubervilliers et regardent
chaque semaine il y as grand nettoyage
sous l'oeil du patron l'adjudant ligier
c'est comme dans la marine tout le monde
est sur le pont pour astiquer le navire
d'ailleurs le fait que les pompiers de
paris soit des soldats pose quelques
problèmes depuis la fin du service
militaire il n'ya plus les appeler
volontaire et la brigade manque de
personnel
les salaires sont attractifs 1400 euros
pour démarrer plus de 9000 francs mais
les contraintes sont lourdes
quatre-vingt dix heures de permanences
chaque semaine ça c'est le côté
militaire à la brigade m'ont surtout ce
qu'elle nettoyage propreté des locaux
entretien on est vraiment on est
maniaque parce que on a on se plaint
souvent de manquer de moyens au niveau
de nos casernement d'aller casernement
qui sont ces vieux et on sait que si on
les entretient pas personne ne le fera
pour nous ménage
les cuisines les corvées c'est pour les
petits nouveaux l'intérieur
le sapeur bouillie qui a passé toute son
enfance dans la caserne de sant pere le
savez aujourd'hui il est de cuisine
c'est les sapeurs qui s'occupe de tout
ce qui est travaux d'intérêt général
donc et après c'est vrai que les postes
qui sont attribués en fonction de
l'ancienneté à peu sachant que celui qui
a 10 ans d'ancienneté mais qui est quand
même sympa elle va pas se faire la
plonge alors qu'il ya quelqu'un qui a eu
tout neuf mois de service la fera donc
c'est un peu normal je sais pas que ça
nous plaît c'est si on le fait pas
personne ne fait donc sachant qu on est
à peu près 20 par jour dans la caserne
si on fait par la planche si on fait pas
le ménage
si on fait rien on est vite fait dans
une porcherie donc ce soir faut bien le
faire cela paraît raisonnable mais il y
aussi l'oeil dégradé tout doit être
impeccable pour la revue de détail deux
fois par jour cet après midi on appelle
saint denis là pour le lave linge
parce qu'on doit voir le réparateur on
la paye là au niveau des douches tout
fonctionne race race c'est ras rien à
signaler
on est 50 ans il ya trente célibataire
c'est à dire des jeunes qui est des
jeunes y habituer à la maison à tout
faire faire part à leurs parents un le
petit déjeuner je range pas ma chambre
et je fais pas mon linge donc il ya
intérêt de surveiller ce ça pourrait
très vite et 1,1 montrent nos à la
maison qu'est ce qu'ils faisaient une
petite et jaune et maman qu'est ce qui
faisait le l'âge c'est pas moi non plus
les sapeurs d'aubervilliers sont jeunes
les nouvelles recrues ont entre 20 et 22
ans les jeunes aujourd'hui recherche
cette autorité
paradoxalement l'autorité qui l'ont pas
eue dans la famille il a recherché ils
ont besoin 10ème sache chef de centre
retrouvez cette autorité quelqu'un de
bienveillant et quelqu'un qui les remet
en place quand il ya besoin des guides
l'a vraiment le bible le père de famille
[Musique]
une famille où l'on a souvent l'ordre de
quitter la table avant la fin du repas
[Musique]
l'appel provient de la gare rer du stade
de france
un homme est passé sous un train c'est
l'intervention que tous les pompiers
redoutent
est parti chercher une vache au cadavre
de la shdm automne à paris vous faites
le mais où vous essayez de trouver et
nous manque que le pied une personne se
jeter sous le train
au milieu des voies on sait pas si la
personne a été poussée aussi s'est jeté
pour se suicider c'est assez fréquent
c'est une en violant les membres
sectionnés
on a un traumatisme crânien très grave
la personne était son adjudant ligier a
vu beaucoup de corps déchiquetés mais il
sait que pour un débutant cela peut être
insupportable quand on fait ce genre
d'intervention si tu te sens bien aussi
là c'était la première fois je te
laisser faire pourquoi hésiter à venir
voir le chef de garde
et puis lui dire si ça va pas et ça vous
passez le mot avec les gars qui sont
avant le temps que toi les interventions
difficiles comme ça vous prend vous voir
tomber dans les pommes devant les gens
j'ai connu des sapeurs pompiers qui
supporte très mal ce genre
d'intervention on a des gens qui
s'habituent y ait des gens qui
s'habituent pas et ces gens là me faut
les protéger il ya toujours une mission
à leurs données de façon rester en
retrait les gens pour l'image de sapeurs
pompiers le sapeur pompier qui va tomber
dans les pommes sur un accident aussi
grave alors que les gens ont besoin
plutôt d'être rassurés quand ils voient
arriver les sapeurs pompiers
on a des garçons qui veut plus aguerris
qui eux vont pouvoir aller directement
au contact
ils viennent de donner le feu vert aux
conducteurs pour qu'ils dégagent son
train
l'an dernier ils ont ramassé les débris
de 55 personnes mortes sous des trains
ou des métros dans la région parisienne
mais le chiffre total de leurs sorties
et plus impressionnant encore 455 me
l'an dernier chaque jour 1240 départs
comme celui ci au milieu pompon le
caporal michael pondemer un breton de 25
ans pompier de paris depuis cinq ans et
quelques désillusions beaucoup de
supports avec les parisiens ils ont
tendance à nous appeler moi
sa part des vingt-sept
le seulement besoin d'un médecin
traitant et les personnes sont encore au
18 septembre d'après les concret c'est
gratuit c'est plus rapide
s'appelle en et cinq minutes on est 100
places risquent six appels à sos
médecins
il faut il faut des heures en plein là
c'est la patronne d'un café qui les a
appelés elle veut se débarrasser d'une
cliente avinés mais la cliente ne veut
pas partir
la patronne du bistrot affirme que la
poivrote est malade et qu'il faut
l'emmener à l'hôpital
nous devons nous mettre debout des
marchés ou deuxième pas transporter
l'hôpital j'habitais au marbre mais les
pompiers ne peuvent rien faire sans
l'accord de cette dame
madame marché un petit peu là qu'on voit
si cela est avec nous vas-y marché la
dame semble capable de rentrer chez elle
ils sont venus pour rien au revoir jean
s'attendait à ce qu'on en prenne en
charge en maintenant à l'hôpital
ok c'est élise elle avait pas manger vos
pas l'emmener à l'hôpital parce qu'elle
n'a pas mangé
apparemment elle a de l'argent pour
s'acheter à boire c est un casse croûte
des fois les pompiers ça donne bonne
conscience aux gens oui bord ils sont
contents ils ont fait leur travail ils
ont été conclus pour essayer se soulager
et une voix qu'est ce qu'on a fait pas
grand chose
c'est pas d'urgence qui essaie ça plus
interventions de secours estime
deschamps n'en sait toujours pas plus
ces secours à victimes se sont toutes
les interventions qui ne concerne ni le
feu ni les accidents et en 15 ans elles
ont augmenté de 273 % alors que les
effectifs des pompiers ont un peu
diminué
il est 22 heures à la caserne de
ménilmontant normalement les pompiers
sont de garde pendant 24 heures
comme beaucoup de ses collègues pompon
cumule les gardes il en fait trois
d'affilée 72 heures tous ceux qui sont
aux premiers secours évacuation viennent
dormir ici ça permet de décaler plus
vite on dort pas beaucoup ça peut aller
de nuits blanches jusqu'à aller de 3
heures beaucoup
vous avez combien de temps pour préparer
fait c'est le plus vite possible dans la
minute faut que l'engin a quitté à kazan
ça veut dire deux jusqu'à l'engin en
fait on a dit j'espère
[Musique]
elle presse décalée
pour moi la paix
[Musique]
cela faisait moins d'une heure qu'il
s'était endormi le premier sommeil
bon 1
c'est dur car ils sont appelés parce
qu'une personne âgée ne répond pas aux
appels de sa petite fille qui tente de
la joindre par téléphone
ils ont pris la grande échelle car ils
savent qu'il leur faudra entré par une
fenêtre
[Musique]
c'est au cinquième et dernier étage de
l'immeuble que se trouve l'appartement
derrière cette fenêtre aux volets fermés
vous pouvez trouver un carré en bas ça
peut être personne comme une personne
décédée la zucca ce carreau faut rentrer
à l'intérieur d'un appartement sur la
fenêtre elle emprunte ouvrir toute seule
la voie là impeccable
là on n'a même pas attention carreau
ils ont une bonne surprise la vieille
dame était endormi dans sa chambre elle
nous avait pas entendu frapper à la
porte
bah vous est pas venu alors mon père de
me tourner ça fait cher le petit
personnage et il y en a beaucoup
whissell sous les oubliera coucher
téléphone ou même des fois ils veulent
paraître de téléphone où il veut pas
ouvrir la porte comme l'acétone calais
tnt se sont vite remplies la famille en
province
ils appellent ils voient qu'il ya
personne qui répond tout de suite on
vendait compris pour aller voir s'il ya
vraiment quelque chose
madame nous à prendre congé comme si on
vous on va prendre congé oui d'accord
donc j'ai rappelé
petite fille elle est plus inquiète
maintenant tu restais là oui on a
discuté au téléphone apparemment vous
devez aller en maison de retraite
bien sûr et où elles s'en vont mais sur
d'autres non mais ça vous verrez une
petite fille allez on y va parce que
tout à faire non pas sur des gens sont
inquiétés donc voilà c'est ça c'est pas
un docteur non allez madame parce que si
c'est un pays à comprendre à l'état
si beaucoup de pompiers de paris cumule
les gardes c'est parce qu'il n'habite
pas paris
leur vie est ailleurs lorsqu'il a fini
c'est 72 heures de service pompon
retourne chez lui sa maison est à 400 km
à dol de bretagne en ille et vilaine
il fait à peu près 120 aller ou retour
par an il n'est pas le seul dans leur
majorité les pompiers de paris habite en
province
dol de bretagne c'est là que se trouve
la maison de pompes ont ainsi que sa
femme fabienne ils se sont mariés il ya
un an et demi elle travaille comme
secrétaire
ils attendent leur premier enfant ce
soir ils ont invité les parents de
pompon ça vous démarrez attention mais
on va éviter de le casser voudrait
qu'ils feront pieds dans l'eau
moi ça sera bien qu'il prenne la relève
bon on verra ça c'est s'il veut aussi
s'il n'a pas envie ne fera pas non le
forcera pas non
baboo n'ayant un père pompier en général
dans mon père était pompier n'a pas
demandé 1 c'est moi qui ai voulu tout
seul j'habitais juste à côté
je tenais là dedans en fait le risque
vous y pensez merci on y pense forcément
ce qu une mie câline profession à risque
d'en prendre
on y pense je pense qu'il faut tension
je pense mais le monde c'est pas
toujours évident puis bon ce rôle c'est
d'aller sauver les gens c'est pas c'est
pas de dieu j'y vais parce que les
risques pour s'abreuver sauver les gens
les enfants les animaux mari le père
était pompier volontaire à dole il n'y a
pas que le père l'autre fils le cadet de
pompon est également pompier volontaire
au cours des soirées familiales les
conversations tournent un manque
ablement autour des pompiers a commencé
c'est qu'ils sont tous confié dans votre
famille ce qu'ils aiment ça c'est
dansant
ils me suivent sont son frère aussi bas
il voudrait bien il dans les pompiers de
paris aussi oui mais dans la loi c'est
parce qu'il a tenté sa chance et il a
échoué
il a recommencé à tenter sa chance à 3
pts et sachant cela c'est vrai quand on
aime ça certes les pompiers de paris
c'est l'élite quoi c'est la discipline
c'est c'est le respect c'est le respect
de tout le monde quoi ils ont bonne
réputation
ouais ouais je pense la basse et des
héros à paris non je fais mon travail
comme un autre
c'est un métier comme un autre j'ai très
fier mais tellement d'avoir un fils qui
a fait ça c'est pas il ya un monde
je voulais te l époque les parents
pouvaient pas nous faire faire ce truc à
lui s'est fait tout seul bah oui c'est
une très belle région
à bas la vie de famille dans les
pompiers de bonne famille c'est une même
embêtant c'est une main comme des gosses
bien comment on est en train de manger
son parti revienne quelquefois prend
quatre heures après des besoins à 0 oui
on va pas toujours en faut toujours un
on est content de faire quand c'est un
bouffeur on est content qu'il vous
revenez dans un état épouvantable où la
veillée tenu alors là les femmes là-bas
c'est pas marrant a toujours tendance à
parler du pompier on donne beaucoup de
temps mais faut penser à la femme donne
beaucoup de temps fait toujours il la
voit d'autant moins que lorsqu'il est à
dole il n'a rien trouvé de mieux à faire
que de s'inscrire comme pompier
volontaire à part lui il n'y a pas de
professionnels ici il est le plus gradé
le caporal à paris est sergent chef à
dole j'étais déjà volontaires ici à
vendetta la brigade des pompiers
volontaires simple en plus comme il en
faut comme on est en manque deux
pompiers volontaires
c'est important de venir les
connaissances donné son savoir faire
c'est important et même les autres
qu'ils aiment bien
est ce que c'est bien là paraît faux
cadeaux les roues cité dans une descente
même pensé à mettre le frein à main
aussi ça peut servir
là on va simuler que la porte ne peut
pas l'ouvrir à dole ce n'est pas le
rythme de paris on est loin des 36
départs quotidiens
si déjà fait savoir leur parler un là
n'a pas trop grande les engueuler quand
même gagné la centrale et à côté ainsi
la part des pompiers volontaires
en fait il s'en fiche on peut s'en aller
du jour au lendemain c'est pour ça il
faut quand même faire attention à ce
personnel et moi je suis chouchoutée
mais bon
la moyenne à dole c'est trois départs
par jour sa dalle 16 2 vs air doll kung
réseau celle d'alès agents chaque
promeneur plus deux hommes accès en
circulation rn176 sens pourtant
cendrillon dès lors que par
l'intervention que ce soit paris au dol
c'est la même chose là la mission est la
même et en assurera 100%
avec mon frère on dégaine en famille
mais à dole c'est rarement pour des
broutilles
cette voiture est sortie de la route
depuis moins d'un quart d'heure
elle a fait plusieurs tonneaux les
pompiers volontaires du village voisin
sont déjà sur place le conducteur
s'était endormi au volant sa femme et
blessé pour l'instant dans le coma ok
c'est le mari l'homme à la casquette est
indemne et vous posez des inconnus
cervicales aller comment la vente il si
elle vante il sait qu'elle respire le
couple venait d'un village voisin
des fois c'est un peu lourd un ton tout
ici surtout quand je suis dans mon
centre de secours à dol de bretagne chez
volontaire c'est on est confronté
souvent des personnes qu'on connaît là
c'est un peu plus touchants et c'est
vrai que là des fois c'est un peu dur
tout d'un coup les choses vont plus mal
ça se passe comment c'est son coeur qui
vient de s'arrêter tout de suite un
homme tente de le relancer
2 3 5 6 7 8 9 10 ou non le mari c'est
que vont elles été blessées un peu plus
grave que lui mais on lui a pas dit ce
que c'est exactement pour la folie
le médecin du samu arrive de saint malo
20 minutes d'arrêt et puis tout d'un
coup le que repas voilà apparemment là
est toujours inconsciente mais elle a
repris à la une ventilation et 1 cuil
elle est plus en arrêt cardio
ventilatoire les médecins vaincu la
femme vers l'hôpital mais le choc avait
été violent elle ne résistera pas elle
est morte dans la soirée la caserne
d'aubervilliers il est deux heures du
matin la sonnerie vient d'annoncer un
incendie dans ce cas il décale en moins
d'une minute
[Musique]
d'autant qu'ils apprennent tout de suite
que c'est dans un hôpital que le feu a
pris l'hôpital bichat dans le 18e
arrondissement l'un des plus importants
de paris en arrivant sur place
effectivement des odeurs de fumée
l'hôpital bichat ce sont plusieurs
bâtiments des kilomètres de couloirs et
plus de mille malades alités
lorsqu'il arrive on leur dit que le feu
viendrait des sous sols
c'est
devant le risque considérable plusieurs
casernes ont envoyé leurs camions
[Musique]
il y a déjà des pompiers partout mais
personne n'a encore réussi à localiser
le feu le pompier de l'hôpital pense que
c'est une buanderie qui brûle au fond de
ce couloir avec leurs masques
les pompiers peuvent tenir vingt minutes
dans la fumée sans lui en deux minutes
c'est la syncope
avant de s'engager davantage ils doivent
avoir une bonne idée de ce qui les
attend celui qui bull s'est très
longuement passent les portes ce qu'on
passe les parts du fonds et ont pas nos
citoyens nos jeunes à gauche veulent à
tout prix romain chalon part à gauche
voilà le bayer sur la droite
effectivement une brune foule par ces
partis
[Applaudissements]
petit planque sur colony mis dans la
tente
on est toujours non de couleurs ce n'est
donc pas la buanderie le sang froid des
pompiers est impressionnant fait ils
savent que le feu ne peut pas se
propager tout de suite aux étages
supérieurs
le bâtiment a été construit selon des
normes qui permettent de le contenir
pendant au moins deux heures au même
étage
l'équipe d'aubervilliers tente de passer
par un autre accès depuis un parking une
rampe mène au sous sol où cela brûle là
c'est pas la peine de s'engager là on
rate donc la north et par là c'est ici
que ça se passe
en fait c'est une baraque de chantier
installé dans les sous-sols du bâtiment
qui brûlait
il est probable qu'un mégot mal éteint
avait enflammé une poubelle qui a mis le
feu à la baraque
il leur avait fallu une heure pour
trouver
le 31 décembre en fin d'après-midi la
caserne d'aulnay sous bois
les spécialistes du feu de poubelles et
des incendies de voitures s'apprête à
fêter la nouvelle année
ils ont prévu de recevoir une centaine
d'invités leur famille et des amis
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
la caserne d'aulnay est la seule de la
région parisienne qui a été construite
au milieu d'une cité pour le 31 décembre
les pompiers ont installé des
protections à leurs fenêtres la caserne
prend des allures de blockhaus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les deux hommes qui veillent aux
standards savent que la nuit sera agitée
et
[Musique]
m
ça coince plutôt qu'à prier les
festivités on sait quelle heure brassant
les attaques connues mais en plus tôt
pour partir
papé ce point encore france véhicules
aux sites et les blogs
m
mus contre un plus c'est au niveau des
cités vont faire leur fête à eux c'est à
dire que pour eux c'est de l'amusement
de
je
provoqué des feux et qui a amené la
police tout ça sert à recommencer le jeu
chez as oui on est là pour être un
effort n'est pas là pour ce rendez vous
ce qui est malheureux à dire c'est un
jour ça pour arriver que l'on sera en
train de se faire caillasser pour des
bêtises
alors il y aura vraiment un beauf
d'appartements qu'il y aura des gens qui
sont naître
heureusement on sera pas on sera pas
lensois sion bloqués pour des bêtises
les scores évacuation a dans le lait
chaud quoi se présente
[Musique]
ouais je sais j'ai un collègue qui
arrivent là son retour
en fait ce n'est pas une voiture qui
brûle mais deux des riverains
s'inquiètent
la police a dépêché pas mal d'hommes sur
place il semble que les responsables du
maintien de l'ordre s'attendent à ce que
cet ordre soit sérieusement troublé
apparemment la police d'après si
l'information est ce qu'elle a vu la
journée il y aurait eu quelques groupes
de jeunes qui auraient préparé des
cailloux le long des trottoirs là au
milieu de la cité
maintenant pourquoi faire je ne sais pas
on verra pour nous pour la police on les
rend généralement pour les deux
regardez
on surveille un petit peu on sait jamais
quoi normalement la police a sécurisé la
place mais bon sait jamais des petits
filous alors que ce métier la deuxième
voiture continue de brûler le réservoir
catherine ans seulement ces explosions
ce sont les pneus de la voiture en feu
qui éclate
[Musique]
lorsque le camion arrive le feu s'est
propagé à une seconde voiture qui
stationnaient
la nature s'éveille bâtir
[Musique]
maintenant
à la caserne
on essaye de faire comme si de rien
n'était on essaye de faire la fête
les premiers invités arrivent les
pompiers qui ne sont pas de garde sont
en civil
le capitaine nadal n'est pas de
permanence ce soir c'est le capitaine
guesdon qui assure le commandement
parmi les invités des admiratrices des
hommes qui étaient partis sur des feux
de voitures reviennent à la maison
la zone est ressorti sandwich 5 est
encore temps la grande question combien
de temps va-t-on restos c'est paris on
n'oublie pas une 5 minutes 10 minutes à
un quart d'heure une heure on verra bien
la garde est l'équipe qui assure la
permanence est convié à la fête
mais la table qui lui est réservé est la
plus proche de la sortie
le pompier a toujours autant de succès
on met dans l'embarras une femme est
derrière attention c'est vrai que
certains précisent les formes au 14
juillet on attire l'attention d'ailleurs
c'est vraiment deux jeunes filles
autochtones heures cela a duré dix
minutes est à nouveau une alerte
les parements mal
[Musique]
et rés emporté que nous y sommes
contraints j'étais dégoûté parce que sur
toute la première série première on peut
acheter et je vais logiquement 2002 on
mange pas
encore une voiture en feu mais cette
fois des crs ont été envoyées sur place
soucy a encore une fois la police
pendant les effectifs de plus que tout à
l'heure déjà
donc c'est rassurant bon j'ai toujours
un petit coup d'oeil quand même voir si
à pas cher un spécial à l'intérieur ça
vous est déjà arrivé de trouver des
bouteilles de gaz ou les choses comme ça
quoi mais qui seront pourtant cette
poubelle voie publique 8 allée des roses
aulnay sous bois
c'est à quelques minutes de là qu'on les
appelle pour ce feu de poubelle en fait
ce n'est pas un feu qu'il découvre mais
beaucoup de feux de poubelles allez
[Musique]
quelques jeunes du quartier sont venus
au spectacle
les jeunes garçons à peine des
adolescents qui viennent les provoquer
chacun s'amuse comme il peut
ça peut toujours là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le capitaine vient d'être alerté un
camion de premiers secours rencontrent
des difficultés ils décident d'aller sur
place vous passez devant lyonnais c'est
un plaisir quoi
bien compris c'est un cours décoté
surfaite poubelles thomas public parce
que des jeunes qui réussissent tout ça
qui ne voit plus le fouta font naviguer
nénuphars s'est engagé à pied alors là
comment se faire insulter tout ça ils
sont
d'après vous avez des problèmes
maintenant c'est fabrice de convocation
je n'aurais où il y à un premier feu de
poubelle qui est accessible mais s'il y
en a un autre tout au fond du cul de sac
les pompiers craignent un piège il n'y a
pas de risque de propagation du feu le
capitaine n'exposera pas ses hommes
[Musique]
c'est toujours lorsqu'il s'en vont
qu'ils risquent les caillassages
une vitre cassée la deuxième ce mois-ci
[Applaudissements]
compagnie j'en parle et j'ai le monde le
passage en niveau orange du plan
troubles urbains zone d'éboulement
initial carrefour de l'europe en passant
les pompiers ont une échelle pour
qualifier les troubles urbains le niveau
vert c'est lorsqu'ils font face sans
problème à tous les feux le niveau
orange c'est lorsqu'il commence à ne
plus pouvoir tout éteindre à cause de la
quantité de feu ou des menaces
d'agressions ce soir là ils n'iront pas
jusqu'au niveau rouge le stade où ils ne
peuvent plus éteindre les feux parce
qu'il y en a trop
quelques jours plus tard dix jeunes ont
été interpellés ils ont été placés sous
contrôle judiciaire et plusieurs d'entre
eux ont été mis en examen pour violences
urbaines
juste avant minuit les pompiers en
étaient à une vingtaine de sorties sur
leur secteur
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
marie rivale à condamner
là
[Applaudissements]
ah la la
les sorties ont continué jusqu'à 6h du
matin au total 42 voitures ont été
détruites par le feu dans le département
deux fois plus que l'année précédente
quatre véhicules des pompiers sont
partis en réparation comme dans quelques
autres villes de france
à aulnay sous bois les pompiers se lasse
de l'absurde comportement de quelques
gamins de banlieue des incendiaires du
1er janvier avait entre 12 et 15 ans
[Musique]